have you had your fill of exploring
Hyrule and murdering the cob lens and
Zelda breath of the wild well if you're
in need of some new games then I've got
some good news more of them have snuck
their way onto the eShop I'm Matt and
this gamespot news update is about to
switch things up there are four new
games out on the switch this week
including geometric shoot-'em-up
graceful explosion machine neogeo
classic shoot-'em-up alpha mission to
and magical bike action game room in the
night sky the biggest release for this
week however is lego city undercover
which received an 8 out of 10 in game
sports review of the wii u version on
top of all that the switch also gets a
demo of Just Dance 2017 you know in case
you're in the mood for a little dancin
the nintendo switch came out a month ago
and it already has a library of more
than 25 games some of the best on the
platform includes zelda breath of the
wild snipper clips and The Binding of
Isaac afterbirth plus you can like and
subscribe to stay up to date on all of
the switches new releases but if you
want to set your eyes on something that
comes out this year check out our video
review of ukulele
[Music]
you